joining us now to expand on this and so
much more Fox News contributor former
white house chief of staff Karl Rove
Carl I sometimes think we need to
recalibrate once in a while I don't
think I have to tell you to be patriotic
but do you think sometimes people forget
how great this place is
oh absolutely and thanks for doing this
segment I'm it was a surprise to me and
I'm it was a very pleasant surprise
you're right as a country we focus on
the bad things but we don't understand
and put them in the context of what this
country is and what it represents around
the world you know even the problems
that we have on the southern border
people are coming here not because they
think it's a hell hole they're coming
here because they believe in what they
have heard about the American dream the
ability of people of modest backgrounds
to rise in life based on hard work and
energy and commitment and uh you're
right we we are such a grand country
that has done so much for uh for the
world I was talking this morning just by
coincidence with the ambassador to the
United of the United States to the
country of Netherlands which has the
second largest U.S military cemetery
abroad and it is it is the graves there
are tended by volunteers Dutch
volunteers who come and tend those
Graves and why do they do that because
the United States came in a World War II
helped to liberate their country and the
only thing we ask for in return was
ground in which we could place our dead
and uh you know that's that's the United
States of America and God bless the uh
the the founders of our country for
setting us in the direction they did
absolutely so easy to take it for
granted that's why you got to go out of
your way not to let's talk about what's
happening at the border we've never seen
anything like this Karl Rove and there's
been talk about immigration problems and
proposals but we've never seen which
looks to be basically an invasion you
know in El Paso alone there's an
increase of 255 percent and when title
42 goes away on the 21st we are
expecting uh about 18
000 illegal immigrants a day we can't
handle five what are we going to do
where is President Biden on this
yeah look let's put this in a little bit
of context because we do have a big
Border in the South and it takes a lot
to protect it we call those encounters
that's when this the CBP the border
patrol takes into custody somebody on
the southwestern border and FY 20 there
were 458 000 of them that's the fiscal
year that ended at the end of September
2020. 2021 there were a million seven
hundred and thirty four thousand fiscal
year 22 which ended at the end of
September of this year 2 million three
hundred and seventy eight thousand think
about that that is over a 500 percent
increase in three years and in October
wow the first month of the fiscal year
230 000 encounters across the border the
anticipation is is that an FY 22 there
were 600 000 getaways those are people
who come across the border and are not
apprehended and processed by the border
patrol this is a gigantic humanitarian
crisis these communities are being
overwhelmed now we saw recently and said
in in El Paso a town of 678 000 people a
thousand people primarily from Venezuela
and Central and South America came
across literally there was no space in
the shelters these people spent the
night on the streets grabbing you know
whatever kind of uh cardboard or paper
that they could in order to start fires
to keep themselves warm we saw that but
that is happening in smaller towns all
across the border where where you know
Eagle Pass OR Yuma Arizona and it's
amazing that that that that we only grab
it when we get into a big city and it
collapses because a thousand people have
come across in a town of nearly three
quarters of a million people not not
that that ain't what's happening now in
these smaller towns they're being
overwhelmed almost every day by 250 or
300 people coming and think about the
states that got to write big checks of
their taxpayer dollars like the
operation Lone Star in Texas and the
operation in Arizona and with you know
in New York the mayor's asking for a
billion dollars this is money for the
American people paid for tax dollars by
the American people but things got to
change and I think they know that in
fact here's some Democrats weighing in
tell me if you call Rove have a Reason
for Hope here
I don't know why they keep avoiding the
Border uh and say there's other things
more important than this in the Border
if there's a crisis show up just show up
we sent a letter very similar three
weeks ago that said Hey where's your
plan we never got a response back
um would you ask them to wait I think
that if they don't have a plan then they
need to wait to end I think important
for the administration to recognize it's
a crisis we all know it's a crisis when
you have a crisis in your country you
should deal with it elections are over
three Democrats weighing in admitting
what we all know is their hope there
last minute
yeah the Republican house is going to be
able to work with people like Henry
Cuellar of Laredo to add Riders into the
Appropriations Bill to put some policies
in place and I thought it was also
interesting John tester who's up for
election in a red state in 2024 jumped
on top of this he's not on the southern
border he's at the opposite end of the
country but yet he understands how this
is being taken so seriously by the
American people Republican Democrats are
independent they think this is a crisis
and they do not understand why the
administration is so passive and out of
touch when you have the homeland
security secretary saying the border is
secure and they're seeing these pictures
on the Evening News the American people
know it's not secure he should not be in
Delaware this weekend he should be on
the border how hard is it to do your job
call Rove thanks so much always
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else